[Music]
[Applause]
I sound evil for saying I don't rate
people's stuff
try to be hard in Tunes but you're not
Ro think I want to listen to you skinny
Loop up little Coke you live 2 hours out
the city while it's all life around
there just Reds thinking they're sick
made some sheep laugh for 5 seconds I
could do it if I wanted but I'm not
monkey comedians I'm a box full of
lights that won't turn on and I'm going
to Sal to
you I'm
original
yeah I'm
original I'm original original
origal Oh use what I be steaming off
can't jump start a cattle when it's your
own Idols you're ripping
off I'm cold like the drink you're going
to buy me now you want to get to know
me move M of the jungle TR monkey keep
on swimming
around drop some
fruit people deserve good sex go on with
your k f
Sam take your job
[Music]
original I'm
original yeah I'm
original
[Music]
yeah I'm
original I'm
original aim again shoot for the Target
start fresh next time I'll make it the
one that you want the one that you need
the one you keep close the one guarantee
to keep them
quiet to make you one of my own to make
you love again to make you reconcile
it's and only Lo will break your heart
again why I'm
original yeah I'm
[Music]
original you don't know I'm
original all right I'm
original I'm a
[Music]
Reginal I'm
original yeah I'm a
by you
for this is the part where you put your
lighs and hands up in the
a I'm
original I'm
original dirty R Cofe can't yet I'm
original monkey she Mony dude I'm
original whatever he's doing I'll do it
as
[Music]
well
original
yeah I'm AIG
shout out to selector
radio